you're not gonna believe this but the
White House press corps is actually
decided to start working in order to
increase day-to-day transparency the
White House Correspondents Association
is seeking more meaningful and
consistent access to the president LA
Times reporter and president of the whca
Christi Parsons claimed it's time for a
White House Correspondents to band
together in response to a number of
issues including a lack of opportunities
to question the president and the White
House appearing to bypass the press
corps through social media the whca is
urging the President to hold a full
press conference with a rotating pool of
official reporters at least once a month
the Association also wants the whole
freaking on record instead of on
background forcing administration
participants to be recognized by name
instead of as senior officials their
angle is quote a statement we all
support a shared vision of an open and
transparent white house not just for
this White House but four
administration's to come all right I'm
pretty sure I can speak for the whole
panel here when I say that generally the
media does a pretty shitty job am I can
I speak for you guys when I say that
generally when it when it comes to
holding our politicians and our
presidents to account they do a pretty
shitty job okay there yes hey we're
angry are you a boy it's kind of a
give-and-take system there you know the
White House and the press they they kind
of have this kind of mutual jack off
right you know which which is important
to understand yeah except we're the ones
getting screwed yeah there's there's no
there's no there's a lot of cozying up
that goes on there and you know in terms
of access that's often used as a
currency where you know you print that
story you'll never get access to this a
whole other world that you want to cover
blah blah blah so it's always been
corrupt but this this new transparency
yeah garbage it's very so that's that is
a purely garbage because of course for
six years this administration has been
saying it's the most transparent
administration ever meanwhile Snowden
and James clapper the head of CIA lied
to Congress he's fine Snowden's out of
the country and there's a zillion other
examples of that and and all the
backroom dealing and the fact that you
know the fact that bills are passed in
Congress and in the Senate where the
even the representatives themselves
don't even get a chance to have access
to the material in the bill right this
is crazy here's the deal yo in the UK
they have something that's fantastic and
I would love to see it here because here
we're not as polite as they are in the
UK right over the UK they do this thing
called prime minister question time and
and yeah they get really really really
agitated huh and I would love to see
that happen here in America where they
don't know from agitation they don't you
know from from going crazy on somebody
yeah I would love to see that here and
understand why we don't have it yes I
used to do a bit about that actually cuz
they generally yell at each other yell
at each other and yet what we do here is
we got the distinguished gentleman from
Tennessee and it's like you know that
guy's a [ __ ] idiot and it's like we
do this game but is this to me this is
sort of the worst of what I've sort of
not liked about this administration that
they've brought like openness that was
what the idea would ya hey man Osage we
wanted openness but to me there's
nothing better about this administration
in that regard than there was before and
if anything we prosecute more reporters
than ever before I mean you know I
totally get what you guys are saying but
here I kind of feel like you guys are
right but no one wants to know the
complete truth number one number true
yeah two is you want said number true
number two is it sounds like their
feelings are hurt like this baby [ __ ]
they are so sad that the president just
isn't that into them yeah I'm being like
you know they what are they what kind of
demands you know don't want right yeah
it's not fair to go after the press for
trying to do you know what we're
decrying that they're not doing right
now I mean yeah they should be whiny
little [ __ ] one like a completely
transparent when now they're saying
there's an 11 examples of Brian Williams
you know exaggerating the truth I mean
you know which clears no matter by the
way Brian Williams who of course was the
only person fired because of a lie of
the Iraq war that's a whole yeah yeah so
in a weird way while I'm being critical
of Obama here he's just doing what
anyone else would do right if you were
the president wouldn't you do everything
in your power never to sit down
own and answer questions that you didn't
watch it that's all he's doing right I
don't know there's something very wrong
with the entire system from top to
bottom and that's why nobody can speak
openly about it and that's why
transparency is such a threat to the
entire institution so yeah I mean but
you know look I I come from the point of
view that there is no president they can
make a difference this is his system is
so much larger than one person or one
administration that it doesn't matter
and I think that you know I think that
he does a lot of glad-handing he has to
he's the president it's politics and
it's all glad-handing yeah you want to
you want to count wise let's go through
every president ever yeah and you see
who has the fewest so do you kind of by
the the bill Hicks theory you know he
used to do that thing about the day you
become president they show you a file
and it shows well you know okay okay
assassination oh we're like that game
Woodrow Wilson on you have been warned
about it and in in an ascending a graph
chart we've been warned about you know
the development of a shadow government
and it's firmly entrenched I think it
would be either naive or disingenuous to
not believe that yeah how do you how do
you then go on when you win you have
these thoughts all right I I just think
that no one really and I'm saying this
unit wants to hear the complete truth
because a complete truth is there
probably are aliens their problems yeah
I don't know what the answers but I
disagree that a president can make a
change I think we as individuals have to
understand the idea that some one person
is going to change every little terrible
thing is silliness yeah but he has made
a change as far as health care that's
affected my life in a better way in my
children's life so I mean I think that
people do make a change it's not as
grandiose as everybody wants it to be
because everybody wants everything right
now in three seconds and by the way the
president is only one-third
the branches of government people seem
to think that he's a king or want him to
be a king but to your point about the
OVA about Obamacare so he got something
that was passed that worked for you but
if you remember when he was running he
kept saying we're gonna do this all open
it's all going to be on c-span we're
gonna show you how we did it and of
course they didn't do that yeah so it's
an interesting blend of yeah something
good came out of the sausage machine at
the end but you know we wanted to sort
of see the how they do it and it also
depends on your on your perspective like
to me what was good about Obamacare
pales in comparison to the fact there is
a stop to the insurance industry you
know I mean if you if you really wanted
to make change you got to go outside the
system and I just believe that the
system is corrupting you choose and
spits out great statesmen and States
women even the most well-intended of
them but you know let's go back to
transparency what do you know about TPP
what do you know about that what do you
know about they saw me know you have any
idea what's going on but with with water
in this country let alone globally yeah
they can't tell you the truth because
they would be rioting in the streets
yeah so you're never gonna get
transparency well no we filled your
glasses up why don't you guys heard you
guys are rebels we're on it anyway the
point is is there a shadow government do
you believe in aliens what was the
original point of this story that's not
the same thing those two things aren't
the same thing let's go in the comments
right never